faut-il rendre le vote obligatoire en
voilà une question posée depuis des
décennies le vote obligatoire pour
réduire l'abstention
un phénomène déjà d'actualité sous la
quatrième république au nom chacun de
nous était appelée à apporter aux hurle
son ouïe où son nom un trop grand nombre
se refusait à remplir le devoir moral
des citoyens conscients
un brin moralisateur bref le vote
obligatoire a été proposé une
cinquantaine de fois par la gauche comme
par la droite
j'avoue que la question du poids du vélo
obligatoire mérite d'être posée estime
anormal cette non fréquentation des
lieux de vote
c'est un élément qui peut être utile à
la reconquête du civisme à chaque fois
c'est l'initiative de sénateur ou de
député
isolé indépendamment de leur parti loin
d'être partagé par le reste des
parlementaires c'est chez eux que tous
les sénateurs vont vous suivre
non je suis sûr du contraire il ya
peut-être d'autres méthodes
je suis plutôt hostile
ce que je crois que le principe de la
démocratie c'est la liberté ce qui pose
problème c'est que le vote obligatoire
et soit assortie d'une contrepartie la
prise en compte réelle du vote blanc
pour les défenseurs de cette double
mesure trois arguments un peuple
représenter au mieux une abstention
réduite et le vote blanc comme
alternative aux candidats en lice en
2015 voilà ce qu'on pensait la rue il ya
certains politiques qui se disent si la
soupe n'est pas bonne on va obliger les
gens à manger on n'a pas obliger les
gens c'est un droit c'est un devoir pas
quelque sorte
pourquoi pas oui puisque nous sommes
tous citoyens donc votre vote pour pour
nous tous en fait des propositions de
lois mais jamais de vote à l'assemblée
nationale et une abstention qui
s'imposent scrutin après scrutin
pour rappel au premier tour des
législatives de 2010 7 51% des inscrits
ne se sont pas rendus aux urnes et 2%
des votants choisis le bulletin blanc
[Musique]